a las vegas artist still recovering from
kobit 19
months after contracting the virus and
one outlet that he turns to
is his work the i-team's vanessa murphy
shares neil portnoy's story
and what it means to be fortnite
we're at the world famous fortnite
gallery
neil portnoy has called las vegas home
for nearly five years
it's the entertainment capital of the
world and through his caricature art
he's become
a verb have you been portnoyed one of
his latest projects is yet to be
unveiled
at allegiant stadium that's a legacy
that'll be in that stadium
forever the 67 year old's legacy was on
his mind more than
ever in july during his battle with
covid19
words from a healthcare worker stay with
him she said to me you literally died
twice his wife dorothy also contracted
the virus a more mild case
neal ended up in the intensive care unit
people don't realize
how bad it is it gets mentally in your
head
where you know you're not getting any
help you're not getting any better
it's scary it is really scary he credits
the drug rem deserver for saving his
life
months later he's back in his studio all
done for photos
the better the photograph the better the
final piece
he's still recovering after contracting
pneumonia
followed by continued treatment for
blood clots
he says he previously had no underlying
health conditions
he and dorothy took precautions and he
isn't sure how they caught the virus
but he is grateful has this changed your
outlook on life and priorities
absolutely
you know i've got a second chance i'm
going to do things that i wouldn't have
done before
life is very short it's very very scary
and you really need to
not get upset over things that are
really
don't mean much you got to get up every
day
enjoy every day to its fullest because
we just don't know
vanessa murphy 8 news now